well Pearl Skin studio the sponsors of
today's segment recently launched a
strawberries and chocolate body scrub
and facial just in time for Valentine's
Day but we're talking about a lot of
things here to tell us all about it is
Katya simonenko Katya so great to see
you great to see you again so excited to
be here to announce that we're doing
this great treatment and this brand new
treatment for Valentine's Day which is
strawberry body scrub followed by The
Rose spray and chocolate butter it's so
delicious yum okay we can just end the
interview now that's all I needed to
hear that sounds amazing and perfect for
Valentine's Day so can people book it
now is it only on Valentine's Day tell
us about that they can book it now but
they get 25 towards purchasing the
special product only through February
14th and you have it here with us today
and anytime you read anything about skin
care I feel like the number one thing
you always see is sunscreen sunscreen
sunscreen it's so important tell us
about this product and how it works guys
hands down color science is one of the
best sunscreens on the market because
it's physical physical sunscreen
reflects the sun sunlight okay so it can
be used as simple glow on your skin and
it can be used as a primer for your
foundation okay
yes let's see how it works they have our
beautiful model here yes Paige has
beautiful skin she does she doesn't even
need anything on her face it's so
beautiful already but I'm already seeing
the way you're applying this it looks
really thin and light yeah very light
again there's no chemicals it doesn't
clog the skin it has zinc and reflects
the sunlight but if you just want a
simple glow on your skin and kind of go
with your day without putting any
foundation on this is a great option for
you to have that special glow so you can
just put it on and go if you want it
right and then could you put a
foundation or something over it and use
that as a base or primer as well it can
be used as a primer it can be used as a
sunscreen and it can be used as a glow
okay that's great basically you kind of
model to our camera over here and so
there you go you can see with and
without and it just has a nice subtle
hint to again she has beautiful skin but
I feel like this product is great for
everyone are there certain skin types or
people that should be using this or is
it kind of good equipment it's for
everybody it depends if you like that
glowy look and I think we all do and
speaking of glow though in the winter
sometimes your skin can get a little dry
so obviously this product will go a long
way are there any other treatments or
services that you recommend people
getting if they come in and see you and
say they're suffering from dry skin in
the winter yes one of them is brand new
diamond glow facial yes
I love that hydrafacial we are offering
over 50 treatments in our Pearl Skin
studio so you just simply call get
consultation and we'll tell you which
treatment is the right for your skin
type and condition and budget yes that's
great too and so people come in and
aren't sure what to do they could come
in for a consultation or someone there
will examine and tell them what's best
for them yes well Katya thank you so
much for this and I'm really excited
about this product and it looks so
beautiful on you Paige and I think
everyone's really going to love it so
perfect for winter time a great way to
keep your skin glowing looking great the
diamond facial chocolates and
strawberries all that information you
can find right there on your screen
thank you to Pearl Skin studio for
sponsoring this segment you can give
them a call at
702-525-5504 or visit
pearlskinstudio.com book of strawberries
and chocolate body scrub and facial
treatment and like she said receive 25
off color science Unforgettable Total
Protection face shield glow SPF it does
it all when you mention Las Vegas now
we'll be right back